BRIAN SCHWARZ: Hi, I'm Brian,
and welcome to our session
at Google Cloud Next.
This session is going to be
about achieving high resiliency
and availability with
Google Cloud infrastructure.
I'm joined by my friend and
colleague, Chris Schilling.
We're both product
managers at Google
and are excited to talk
to you about this session.
The session today is going
to cover a number of topics.
First we're going
to talk about why
resiliency and high availability
matter in the Cloud,
a little bit about what Google
Cloud provides to customers
as a foundation of the
platform, some of the things
you as a user of
Google Cloud need
to take into account as you
architect your solutions
and applications
on Google Cloud,
and then Chris is going to talk
a little bit about business
continuity planning, and it's a
good idea for all applications
and all systems, and
then we'll give you
some links about how to
find more information.
With this, I'd like to
turn it over to Chris
to get into the content.
CHRIS SCHILLING: Thanks, Brian.
Now let's talk
about why resiliency
and high availability
matter to technologists
building in the Cloud.
Terms like resiliency
can be used
in a lot of different
contexts in IT infrastructure.
We hear the term in the
context of distributed systems,
context of databases, in
the context of networking.
When we think broadly
about what defines
resilient infrastructure,
there are two key components.
First off, that
infrastructure needs
to be able to handle failures
without unexpected data loss.
If there is a network
partition that
results in the loss of
a node, for example,
a resilient distributed
database with many nodes
should be able to
recover without
a split-brain situation.
Similarly, if there is a
disk failure in a resilient
enterprise storage
array, the system
should have copies of that data
available elsewhere to mitigate
against data loss.
So that's the first
component of resiliency.
Failure should not
mean data loss.
The second component is
that resiliency needs
more than one layer of defense.
Just as infrastructure
has multiple components,
from software-defined storage
to the relational database,
to network and access security,
to business logic middle tier,
so too does resiliency.
Resilient infrastructure
will have defense baked
into those layers,
and in certain layers,
multiple lines of defense.
If resiliency is a
fundamentally-defensive concept
focused on your data,
high availability,
on the other hand, is about
your end user's experience.
Highly-available
applications are still
available to the user
even when something goes
wrong with the infrastructure.
That means that your users
shouldn't be adversely affected
when a failure occurs.
An application can be resilient
without being highly available,
or it could be highly
available without resiliency.
We'd all like to achieve both.
And that's why we
at Google Cloud
view these goals as linked.
If your goal is
high availability
for a global
consumer application,
you want to ensure that
an individual hardware
failure in one of
your cloud regions
would not impact your
customer's experience.
That almost always means
thinking about resiliency,
because data loss can be harmful
to your customers, as well.
Similarly, if your
goal is resiliency,
you want to make sure that
all your defensive hard
work to protect
against data loss
and to create layers
of defense will also
have a direct business
impact, ideally
because your
customers never notice
any change to their experience,
even when things go wrong.
So those are linked
goals, both resiliency
and high availability.
When we break down the
requirements for this,
I think the first
one on our list
is infrastructure durability.
It lines up more with the
defensive nature of resiliency
because here we're talking
about providing hardware SLAs,
we're talking about making
sure our data centers are safe,
and we're thinking about how
we respond to escalations
within our network.
A good example of
infrastructure durability
is our public durability service
level objective for Persistent
Disk, our block storage offering
For regional balance PD,
for example, we share that
we had better than 99.9999%
durability, six nines.
Next up is application
availability.
That's something that veers
toward the high availability
goal, because we're thinking
about how to keep a database up
and running through your
transactional applications
or how to move traffic to
the right node or even region
within a distributed
application.
A great product level example
is our high availability
configuration for Cloud SQL,
our managed database offering.
It lets you set up an
architecture designed
to limit user impact if the
primary database system fails.
Last but not least is
business continuity.
We view this as a core
component for both linked goals
because this is all
about planning, checking,
and double checking that you
have an infrastructure safety
net.
That means taking backups
to ensure resiliency,
and it also means testing your
active-active disaster recovery
architecture to ensure
high availability
for your application.
One product that we
have in this space
is our multi-region storage,
which stores your backup data
across multiple Google Cloud
regions in a given continent.
The result is that it's easy
to restore in multiple Google
Cloud regions on that continent,
depending on what your business
continuity plan calls for.
What I would take
away from all this
is that Google Cloud delivers
infrastructure durability
to all our infrastructure
as a service customers.
This is a default setting
for us, not an upcharge
or an option.
If you want to build a
resilient, highly-available
application, we want to
take care of the first step.
The next two steps, ensuring
application availability
and creating a business
continuity plan of attack,
those are equally important.
For them, we offer our
customers tools and services
that they can adopt to
meet specific goals.
We recognize that some tier one
customer-facing transactional
applications will
have requirements
above and beyond an
internal sandbox application
with a few users and no
customer data, for example.
So let's talk about
durability first.
It's a great topic
to kick us off
because Google Cloud
really shines here.
All our customers
get the benefit
of infrastructure
durability that
underpins some of the world's
favorite applications,
like YouTube.
And that starts with storage
for all types of applications.
Our block offering,
Persistent Disk,
our first [INAUDIBLE]
file offering, Filestore,
and our object storage
offering, Cloud Storage,
all count some of the
world's largest enterprises
as customers and users.
Regardless of whether you're
a startup or a Fortune 100
company, you can find the same
public durability information
under Persistent Disk
offerings on our website.
All that information
is available publicly.
We recently published a blog
post to help customers further
understand how we
approach this durability
and what we do to keep
your infrastructure safe.
Similarly, because
we're a service provider
for the infrastructure, we have
operational safeguards in place
to make sure you have a
trusted platform to build on.
That means having encryption
by default, for example,
so you don't have to worry
about accidental leakage
of unencrypted data.
It also means having Site
Reliability Engineering,
or SRE, coverage across a
growing global footprint
and across all of our services.
Many of Google's
SREs have contributed
to the open literature
and public practices
that help make all of us in
product engineering better
at our operations.
You get the benefit of all
this knowledge and the benefit
of having these SREs available
to address service-level issues
when you build on Google Cloud.
I'll hand the rest of
the slide over to Brian.
BRIAN SCHWARZ: Thanks, Chris.
The other part of
infrastructure durability
really comes from our global
data centers and our network.
Our global data centers
are significant.
We have 27 regions
and over 82 zones
built out in many
continents in the world,
and they offer a tremendous
amount of on-demand capacity
and many layers of physical
security in the data
centers themselves.
Of course, we've layered on
top of this infrastructure
sophisticated hardware
monitoring, and all of these
are used to basically offer
the many managed services that
are part of the
Google Cloud network.
And of course, the network--
I always like to tell people
the Google Cloud network scales
and has high availability
because Google
itself has scale and
high availability.
Almost everybody in the
world has some appreciation
for the scale of Google's
consumer services.
You probably use some of
these almost every day.
These same pieces
of infrastructure
and the same network is used
to provide the capabilities
that we offer in the
Google Cloud platform.
And of course, we have
significant investments
in undersea cabling, edge
PoPs, or Points Of Presence,
where we essentially are
peering into the internet
and the network,
and of course, we
have thousands of
edge caches to make
the performance of Google
services and, of course,
the performance of many
Google Cloud services
incredibly performant
and available.
The other thing I'd like
to use is an example
is our networking prowess and
the software-defined networking
we have in Google Cloud
makes it really easy for you
to build on top of this
global infrastructure.
A specific example of
that is the global VPCs,
or Virtual Private Clouds,
that you can build.
They are network constructs
that are very easy to set up
and essentially span
Google Cloud regions.
So you can create one virtual
network that spans a region.
It makes it very easy for you to
build global applications that
take advantage of
this infrastructure
that we've built.
Now let's talk about
some of the things
that it's important
for you to think
about architecting as
you build applications
and services on Google Cloud.
And it's important to
think about applications
in terms of different
types of applications.
I often like to think
about, particularly
in a short session like this,
different types of applications
that would be like web servers
and application servers,
often being stateless apps and
a second set of applications
being databases and very
durable apps, places
where all of your data lives.
And we're going to spend a
little time to talk about each
of those individually.
So if we look at the left
part of the slide here,
the first thing I want to
talk about is load balancing.
So the first two, load balancing
and the GCE, or Google Compute
Engine, auto healing
are really things
to first think about when you're
thinking about application
servers and web servers, that
first category of applications
I mentioned.
Load balancers essentially
redirect traffic away
from unresponsive servers,
unresponsive web servers
or application server.
They may be too busy.
It might be a software defect.
There could be a
lot of reasons why
a node becomes unresponsive.
Load balancing essentially
will redirect traffic away
from these unresponsive
nodes so your customers
and users of the applications
get a great experience.
There are different options on
how you deploy a load balancer.
You can deploy it to
essentially give capabilities
to span zones and regions for
more local load balancing.
There's also options
to essentially do
global load balancing.
So all of your
consumers and users
can come into one single
point, and the application
may actually be spread
across regions, so even
full region outages will be
hidden from your customers.
They'll be redirected to
surviving, healthy nodes.
The second layer of
defense-- as Chris
mentioned, it's good to have
multiple layers of defense
for applications
and web servers-- is
to think about auto healing.
So in Google
Compute Engine, this
is our main offering that
essentially offers VMs.
Many, many applications
run in these VMs,
and there's a construct
that we've developed
called managed instance groups.
It's essentially a set of
VMs that form an application
tier in their environment.
They can essentially provide
a second layer of protection
and availability,
and, essentially,
they will automatically
restart unresponsive nodes.
So a node may be too busy.
It may get somehow
locked in some state
that it can't recover from.
The load balancer will
shift traffic away from it,
and then the GCE auto
healing will come in
to essentially
restart those nodes.
So again, further
rehealing the system.
An important thing
to think about
as you start to build
these layers of defense
is how they work together.
And an example is
you essentially
want the load balancer
to redirect traffic away
from an unresponsive node
before it gets restarted.
So as a perfect example,
you want the health checks
that are in your
load balancer to be
more frequent and aggressive,
and reshift traffic
away from unresponsive
nodes, and then
the managed instance group auto
healing feature to kick in also
has health checks to work
slightly slower to actually go
in and restart nodes.
That way the system
is, in some senses,
self-healing or auto-healing.
The second thing I
want to talk about
is more on the
stateful application
tier, which is why I've talked
about Cloud SQL and Spanner.
So Chris mentioned
Cloud SQL earlier.
You could of course run
a database inside of one
of our VMs.
Many customers
choose to do that.
But it's also great to
think about managed database
offerings to reduce
some of the toil
about setting up and
running a database server.
And that's really where
Cloud SQL comes in.
It's a managed database
service we have.
It supports a lot of common
databases, MySQL, PostgreSQL,
SQL Server, and it has a number
of interesting capabilities
that really add value in
the forms of durability
and resilience and
high availability.
One is using
snapshot-based backups.
You can automate it, so
it takes regular backups.
Let's say every four hours you
have good protection points.
But you can also use it
in on-demand snapshots
if you're going to
do a maintenance
task on your database,
add tables, change
the scheme, et cetera.
You can create a snapshot to
create an easy recovery point.
The managed database
service also
has a built in
capability to offer you
point-in-time recovery
for your databases.
So you have snapshots, and
then you can essentially
move the database to a
particular point in time
based on the logs that
are in the database.
So it's a combination of
the managed database service
working in conjunction
with snapshots
to offer you a
capability to really
be specific at exactly
the point where
the database is
consistent and you want
to restart the application.
It's also great to think
about the high availability
capabilities in the
Cloud SQL offering,
because it offers
failover replicas.
These are essentially shadow
databases that can be set up.
There are options inside the
service that can essentially
run in multiple zones to
protect you from a zone outage.
These zonal things can use
the regional PD offering,
the regional Persistent Disk
offering that Chris mentioned,
so we're synchronously
replicating the data
for the database
underneath the covers.
And then you essentially
have a Cloud SQL instance
that's ready to go in the
event of a zonal outage.
There's also a
capability in Cloud SQL
to essentially do cross
region protection.
This is, of course, an
asynchronous capability,
but it can also protect you
against full regional outages.
So, again, there's a lot
of power and flexibility
in terms of the
offering that Cloud SQL
has in terms of
building in resilience
and high availability.
The last thing I wanted
to think about or talk
to you about in
the database tier
is our Spanner
offering, Cloud Spanner.
This is a really
powerful capability.
It's highly differentiated.
It really comes from
technology that Google
built to scale to the
billions of users we have
on our consumer applications.
It's a fully-managed
database service,
so it's very easy to use.
But it's basically a single
cross regional database.
It's active-active and
read/write in many regions
all at the same time, and that's
really what makes it unique.
So it preserves the
value of standard SQL,
because that's such a common
application programming
language, but it provides you
essentially, in some senses,
you can think about a
cross-regional database
as a continent-sized database
for you to operate on.
So it really allows you
to simplify how you think
about building these systems.
And it comes with a
five-nine availability SLA,
so it's really a
powerful capability
to have in the arsenal as
you think about how you build
applications on Google Cloud.
Now I'd like to turn it over
to Chris for the next part.
CHRIS SCHILLING: Much
appreciate it, Brian.
So let's switch back
to business continuity,
the insurance policy, the safety
net that we all know we need.
Business continuity is
a pretty expansive term.
It can mean a lot of things
from how a cloud architect plans
for disaster,
production [INAUDIBLE],,
to how a storage
administrator tests backups.
You'll noticed I mentioned
planning and testing right
off the bat, and we have a
number of features and services
built for business
continuity purposes, features
like being able to export
a copy of your database
to our object storage for
long-term [? archival, ?]
for example.
But business continuity
is about being absolutely
certain that the data
will be available
when the auditor calls.
That's why the human element
of planning and testing
is so important here.
As the saying goes, an
amateur takes a backup.
A professional tests
that it can be restored.
So when we dial into
a couple of services,
two of interesting ones
that I find differentiated
are our multi-region storage
and our orchestrated backup.
They play different roles in
our business continuity package.
Multi-regional storage
can mean keeping data
in our object storage.
We'll keep two
copies of the data
in two different
regions on a continent,
available in case of a
regional failure or disaster.
This also underpins some
of our other offerings.
It makes it possible, for
example, for our customers
to restore snapshots
stored in North
America to different
North American regions
without having to create
a handful of copies
across the continent and wait
for them to be replicated one
after another.
And on the orchestrated
backup side,
we recently acquired Actifio,
a proven backup vendor
that sells Actifio GO, a backup
as a service offering built
on Google Cloud.
Actifio GO can protect
Google Compute Engine VMs
if you're building in the Cloud.
Or if you're looking at
shifting relational databases
into Google VMs and you
need application-consistent,
agent-based backups similar
to what you have on-prem,
Actifio GO can deliver the
same functionality to you,
allowing you to backup your
newly-migrated database
workloads as frequently
as every 15 minutes.
Best of all, that data can be
stored in multiple Google Cloud
object storage buckets in
different regions and classes,
and it can be restored directly
from object storage, which
means lower long-term
storage costs for customers
with severe data
retention requirements
and easier discussions with
your internal compliance
counterparts when you test
that a backup is available,
for example, without the need
to complicate restores or move
data around to different
block storage options.
These are just two
of our features
that we've created to make
business continuity easier
for you to plan and to test
so that you and your team
can achieve those
goals around resiliency
and high adaptability.
If you'd like to
learn more, we've
included a couple of links
to some interesting content
on disaster recovery, high
availability, and resilience.
In the bottom right,
there's a link
to achieving resiliency and
high availability in Cloud SQL.
It's a video from
last year's Next,
and it covers a
lot of the topics
we've discussed here as they
apply to that managed database
service.
Just above that, we have a
DR planning guide for GCE.
Those of you who are running
stateful workloads and Google
Cloud VMs, we think you'll
find that useful to help you
plan for your DR requirements.
Over on the left, we have
a few sessions of Next
that we think you'll
find relevant.
We've included their titles
and the shorthand name
with numbers so you can
find those in the catalog.
I want to thank Brian for
co-presenting with me,
and I want to thank all of
you for attending our session.